hey guys Greg here so I wanted to
interrupt really quick because you're
doing a YouTube channel for a while
you're bound to have a massive audio
malfunction and sure enough uh we did
the headsets that were normally filmed
with they did not work properly so we
had to rely on backup audio from the
camera itself so audio not as good as it
normally is however uh still put a lot
of work in the video and uh Andrew and
Tara they still killed it should still
be an enjoyable reaction once your ears
get used to the audio either way enjoy
citizens of the reject Nations we tear
Air China gone along with this guy words
came out weird you say your name I'm
fascist excuse me I'm Batman I'm sorry
Flash Gordon so I wanted to repeat the
most famous beloved lines of this film
from the trailer that I saw months ago
what a roller coaster that was wow what
you were timing your community but I'll
leave a comment and then you know what's
up you better bring that back
and also don't forget we call you super
super super super sexy when you get on
patreon because then you can sync up
with your in with your own copy and
watch the all Blue Beetle with me and
Andrew Greg and John cover exclusive
stuff over there with specific reactions
and highlights and you know just get
super sexy get over there you know what
the deal is Blue Beetle I think I
watched a trailer I don't know a lot
about it I'm sure Andrew will open his
book of references you know this guy
he's got a lot I got none so I feel like
we're ready are you ready let's do it
let's do it
[Music]
plugged into the Matrix
oh my God his face is so scarred up
cord Industries yeah
I did not know she was in this I
think mine's longer you think it's
just tend to be for Sunrise
another decoy it's in there getting Man
of Steel Vibes right now yeah I love how
she's the only one in white
that's a good point
whoa this is that the Scarab which is
yeah Victoria Court
missing okay so that's his way if that's
the obvious thing but where is he
missing maybe we'll get an answer that
by the end of the film or one of the
mid-credit post credits
I do like all the cloak and stuff like
that's really cool it's giving me
Predator Vibes I love it yeah Predator
exactly
Miguel okay we love Cobra Kai yes we say
no
I'll tell him that's Loca even good news
and this is pretty bad news I can be
joyful
how was your implied are you hungry of
course yeah that's all they had
she is joyful yeah
well obviously this doesn't take place
in the MCU where I'd say that's it oh
George Lopez
his beard is so long
I'd say that's a reference to Ant-Man if
this weren't them to you he's had his
tacos now let him have the truth the
truth yeah what is it
we're losing the house no wait till he
finishes the tacos
they gave us three months to come up
with the money that sucks tripled we're
gonna have to bust our ass in the shop
right
um Auto Shop's gone yeah wow you can
thank court for that double whammy
heart attack
[Music]
why didn't you tell
is
yeah I can understand why they normally
I would be mad at a family for not
telling him that kind but yeah I
actually too I I understand I'm not
telling him that honestly I do
I love that good good family yeah but I
love like no matter what through the
hardship they're still sticking together
and still trying to you know yeah stay
happy and figure out a way because that
would that would break a lot of people I
was supposed to make it out I was
supposed to get all of us out of here
thanks bro but I like the keys
wow oh is that Ace is that like an ace
chemicals reference that's where the
Joker became the Joker
[Music]
outside of the tracks and now they want
that too
I mean she's got a point I'll get a job
not just any job but a rhyme John
a few weeks yeah like there's no way
buddy telling you in five years we're
gonna be rolling in it because we're
gonna have the Mansion on the water with
the marble everywhere infinity pool I
believe in Jaime she did say the keys as
in like Florida right yeah I believe so
that's what I thought and then I saw the
city I was like well that's not the keys
but this is yes okay got it that's a
sick pad yeah that's awesome in his
imagination did are we just gonna skip
ahead or they actually have it no
see there's oh this song
oh it's in Spanish I love it
or what
it's gonna say does he works I love it
hey girl hey I didn't know you were
coming oh carapax this is Ted's daughter
my favorite niece Jennifer
[Music]
the world has this is her niece by
marriage I would assume
that's what she just said yeah and she
does not agree with cord I guarantee
they're probably
future of private policing
hi I deserve a luxury dump right now all
right nothing like a luxury dump
like if she's not at all worried about
her job right into the human brain so
you get connected to the Matrix
this is it looks
old that's what he has that's what we
saw earlier oh cool security core can we
lie on all right we don't make weapons
anymore you are nothing to this company
a brat in her daddy's board seat
your father was handed a company I built
my company you know what he did just
disappeared and left me to pick up the
pieces okay so they weren't married says
hey she said
back away man uh
that was lavish oh
I think it's time to find a new job
oh boy hey are you okay that was I
appreciate the chivalry but I can take
care of myself okay what a dick right
she's a cord they're all dead
Jenny Port we're not old I'm really
sorry about this give me your phone let
me give you my number okay
come by core Tower tomorrow I might be
able to get you a job somewhere else in
our company you know he has a degree
right you guys need any pre-lawyers
you should hope if he gets married
that's a lot of money for your family
just saying girl can you that's a lot of
family's house real quick it's a lot of
luxury shits for her if they get married
yeah
should I text her shouldn't I oh how
many followers
that's it don't let it all stop you even
get more likes than that I don't think
so yeah you do
I feel like I failed you guys
we're in a journey Jaime
this house the nepales they're just the
stuff in the journey what's important is
that we go on this journey together La
Familia it's forever hmm
I love how positive and brave he's being
and again such a tough situation
everyone has a purpose you just haven't
found yours so what's your purpose then
I'm still searching too I'm just so
scared we're having family moments with
the dad yeah I know how movies tropes go
I'm just worried because I like the dad
a lot
yeah we'll probably lose him and that's
gonna cause him to go into action even
more a hump he's got to get over his Arc
haha
thank you
yeah I look like an just like
everybody else
you're a game bro
[Music]
okay oh is that her I think so she's
trying to be like no weapons how do we
this is how it all begins
that is a cool design though yeah crop
wise oh oh is that what powers
everything must be
ah nice
time for your meeting with Jaime
but she's been there for what like three
hours oh she probably forgot that she
had her yeah she's gonna like run out of
there yes me
and you
people talk to their food
done that I'm really trying to think
because I'm like I wouldn't put it past
me not to
I'm not saying I don't think I do
no I don't maybe in my head I've done it
in my head out loud or like this looks
good yeah I never say it out loud though
you just yeah yeah
dude I just stole some tech come talk to
me later let's talk while you have lunch
please
without
you said you'd do anything right
not open do not touch it don't even look
at it okay I'm just gonna guard it with
my life welcome to South entrances you
too with me uh
I thought they'd be gone this is a
surveyor yeah but doesn't the
surveillance show that she handed it
yeah of course then also it would have
to show that she was in the there's no
way they don't have cameras inside the
testing you haven't looked is that not
to open it
she's not here what
blah
there's surprise yeah I've been eaten
those okay you guys are the ones that
want to see it
oh my God all right guys come on like
hey wait
oh my God whoa
cool
uh-oh whoa
if you're gonna bind with him
I think he likes me
yeah
I think it more than likes you
that reminded me of aliens yeah
[Music]
oh whoa
yikes
[Music]
yeah
oh oh
my God
oh my God
this is dark
what's up
what did he say I don't know he's
turning to Ash OH
oh my goodness
this is like it feels like a horror
movie
whoa whoa
oh that's an awesome matchup with the
poster
whoa oh my God
[Music]
holy to Molly it's like the blue Iron
Man
adjusting pressure for host protection
holy crap he really is in space wow
is that my house testing great entry
systems
[Music]
I don't want to test this why why is it
so fast can you just let me down slow
oh my God yeah you would definitely burn
on re-entry
I'm going that fast
[Music]
whoa whoa awesome perfect
engaged
cool
[Music]
you're gonna take down the bridge kid I
like that he doesn't have control of it
it's more it's more grounded yeah
because if he would have had more
control of it right away it's like wait
how it's like how do you even know
holy
whoa
that was a dark night reference where
with the Backpage takes up side mirror
is he gonna mess up that car oh yeah
stop
it's such a pretty Bentley that
beautiful Bentley I know has it hit you
yet
oh I'm in so much trouble approaching
um
cool cool
that slow motion shot is so cool though
it's the co oh my God
Ah that's awesome the suit's doing a
good job not drawing too much attention
to itself
this home is being demolished yep
hello hi me you could see the blue uh
the beetle was still in his back
that's a really cool effect though with
that that blue light it's almost like
the back of Iron Man just I mean the oh
yeah in the back whoa there you go
she's gonna know how to get this thing
out of me the problem is he just
attracted because the suit was
malfunctioning like or testing there's
so many he attracted so much attention
and Court Industries is probably going
to send someone there is my guess
no police what do you think cord's gonna
do when they figure out that some
Mexican kid has that type of military
Tech inside of them yeah
it's Dr insta she's Brazilian she lives
at the Regent Tower and she's single by
the way live alone if you asked me I
mean
important details
took your truck
the Tacoma hmm nice it's a cool truck
[Music]
s
dude it's a family member you'll get it
I love it
Jenny
oh my gosh you'd think this was a movie
with that kind of timing
[Music]
okay there goes uncle's truck I don't
think he's gonna be happy enough
oh that's great you just hear him
outside yelling about his car I'm
fine
glad you tell me this now
[Music]
be activated by just any person he has
to choose you so I'm guessing it's
chosen you no more blind dates
but we better move fast because my aunt
will kill us all just to get it back
subtle we are going to figure it out we
always do really is the rock of the
family we've dealt with harder things we
can do this yeah I mean he survived a
heart attack and he's still down in
Tequila every night so like this is
nothing yeah come on now there's a place
where we can get some answers but we
need the key and the quote building I've
been working on something that I believe
can help us huh cool I'm surprised like
all the damage they did that he did in
the suit before didn't like cause it to
be a high alert oh right the whole has
to still be there but they may seem like
they cleaned up the house super fast and
like the holes weren't I call it
why when you make something cool you can
call yours whatever you want okay fair
enough uh cupcake you want to hit that
yellow switch there hit the yellow
switch I just did
you give me like once give it a little
always works when you kick things in
classic move
awesome
guys something's happening
ha
that's great
what the hell is this
I used to watch that when I was a kid
probably the same my mom I don't know
when my grandfather died Victoria
thought the company would go to her but
he left everything to my dad instead my
father wanted to steer the company in a
different direction Victoria became
obsessed with the racing my father's
life because seeing how opposite their
families are like when it's built on
love and the others built on his trust
yep it's different when you see the
dichotomies of differences
this is the key
what is he doing here
should we run he's not slowing down
watch out watch out uh Blue Beetle yeah
yeah it's a defense mode cool oh it's
closed just incinerate I love it wow
awesome that is so cool that
transformation oh
is he gonna transform two into his uh he
probably is right or does he have to be
oh yeah
yep here we go
I was expecting this till the end uh
it's a now what the hell is that thing
the Olmec
oh you're going to regret that
defending house
but see he's using everything off
automatic I'm curious if during the film
he's gonna get the manual down
kind of like the fight with AI where
there's only certain things human
instincts can take care of yeah
is he not hearing any gunfire I don't
think that's not I don't care how loud
the music is
[Music]
permission to
take the host yes anything yeah
awesome
[Music]
where are you going come on come on
it'd be nice if talking was a good
fighting tool but unfortunately it's not
these kinds of battles
nice
I like when we can Infuse hand-to-hand
combat in these kinds of battles damn
it's got neutralized
what I don't know put the blades away
would you like to use a different weapon
no I mean we don't have to kill him
eliminating almost like the T-1000 with
those things stop I'm not a killer
command accepted
good yeah so his instincts are helping
him to take care of threats but not kill
he says I'm not a killer he'll
eventually have to probably get to that
phase but
maybe him talking to bad guy in the
beginning was that a line from Iron Man
2 where do you think you're going what's
with this guy
maybe we'll see his communication will
actually save something in these this
fight really is visually it's feeling so
much like the end of the fight
environment one oh
although emotionally it's totally
different
he's gonna kill him run him over come on
Uncle when I tell you pull that
handbrake and pull it hard oh is he
gonna have nice Sideswipe
what would she do
oh
sick snap out of it
I'm sorry I'm sorry
oh that's right he's always naked not
what happened back there my it's like I
feel it in my mind I'm worried as
Humanity might be at risk
his mind
oh well so that's I'm assuming her dad's
house I wonder if I wonder if uh the
aunt kidnapped her brother I'm curious
so she could have the company I don't
know maybe oh or you just went missing
doing it in one of his thing I don't
know a good call I mean I'm sure she
would be she was part of the big part of
the company it was left to him that'd be
a big reason why she would want to get
rid of him
superhero like Superman a metropolis or
The Flash in Central City hey I know you
know those two yeah oh I get it though
it's Centric billionaire your dad was a
great man
I had no idea
like look at this it's like Batman stuff
but like if you had ADHD or something
hey that's my line damn you stink this
is your shirt come on I think there's
some of my dad's clothes upstairs I'm
sure he's the same size as your dad a
long time
whoa self-healing nice
never getting rid of this Beetle out of
my back yeah he obsessed over the scare
it but you would disappear for days and
one day he he left and didn't come back
it was very similar to Ant-Man
I'm a better kisser
I'm going for the kiss in a moment of
vulnerability that's cold yeah such a
movie Trope yeah it was way too soon for
that to happen it's to become one with
the other thing has its own will okay
well who made it can they help us this
wasn't made on Earth got us all night no
way see way it's alien yeah I don't
really like the turmeric I mean you can
use it but whatever
the good news is I figured out how to
get it out why
and the bad news is that you have to be
dead
it's fusing itself to every cell in your
body it's completely coiled around your
brain and there's nothing on earth that
could remove it it's designed to protect
a toast better than alien and Aliens
where it just rips out of you all I
wanted was a job maybe that there's a
maybe what Rudy it's all bad news Okay
this just doesn't get any better
for us I don't understand why you can't
I do feel for him though it's
emotionally a lot to take especially at
22. I think he didn't ask for this like
Superman and Batman fight like they
choose to do that this was just yeah
thrown upon him but I think it'll turn
out to be a blessing in disguise it's
just not in the monetary value he was
hoping for look at your old man he
brought me here from Sonora to get us
all here and to keep us all together and
not that he wanted to he had to the
universe has sent you a gift I met and
you have to figure out what you're going
to do with it maybe this did all happen
for a reason it's by far my favorite
part of the movie is the family dynamic
they're heading to his house where are
they going
all right time to disintegrate that that
uh the old track suit
modify
get rid of the clothes first because
they're gonna disintegrate again yeah
that's a cool tracksuit
Up Up and Away web Shazam you said this
thing is gonna protect me right yeah
it's not gonna let me die no no I mean
die jump off the roof buddy let's do it
heck yeah I love that that's great
the amount of clothes disintegration but
then again he can't get naked in front
of the girl he's kind of got a crush on
don't touch my family get up let's go up
up Miss core we found the family damn
Uncle Rudy wasn't crazy after all
[Music]
I gotta imagine Jenny's gonna help
replace everything she's got money
don't say nothing
come on Amy there he is I could use that
Arsenal right about now God you never
asked me I love it like others starting
to have a Jarvis Tony Stark personality
uh relationship I love it that's great
let's see what you can do Target the
family no
I swear if anything happens to the Dad
we write it
oh God she don't kill him
yeah that's more like it whoa
cool cool yeah
that's awesome
yeah I was like oh the house has to be
on fire now I was like does that suit
have water great tracking shot circling
around too oh my God this is so cool
ah oh no
oh no no no
come on get get up get up come on oh
good job oh no you are so rude you just
had an old man I hope that guy dies
he's the bravest dad ever
no oh my God thank you get rid of him I
have a weapon I suggest we Retreat No
Way
listen to the vote
the suit knows it's uh its threshold oh
no I hate it I hate it yeah
oh
damn it
crap
oh no
these are so soulless
foreign
I know Jenny did not mean for any of
this to happen she was just trying to
get proof on what her aunt was doing but
this is a big part of her fault but
[Music]
it was literally The Rock
is
hardly as a family
Jenny does him come with me
if you want to live
I do like how it was grandma getting
them going yeah
it's the oldest that are in this family
that have the heart of it and and the
glue of getting them going yeah the
oldest are the wisest let's hope this
court Tech works
I'm gonna try that from now on when
something doesn't work just just kick it
a couple times see what happens my flat
tire kick it
whoa the beetle mobile cool
that's awesome
dope
whoa that's really cool
it's gonna say is this okay for the
grandma to be on like at this speed and
all that at her age honestly she looks
like she's having a blast
this thing Bulletproof
um
grandma just has a lemon always be
prepared guys want to see dad's toys
yeah we do
oh yes we got this covered we are now an
army of support is that
good do these things work some of them
sometimes
cool how are we supposed to learn how to
use these things
trial and error yeah yeah
how do you know how to hold that so
perfectly
[Music]
okay don't mess with Grandma Pago is a
Caribbean island off the coast of Cuba
from Batista in the 50s places of
Fortress okay how the hell are we gonna
get in there yeah
easy to get and we got in already
originally
the generators are here we could blow
them up and knock power outage
it's really interesting it's great
what are you doing
there's a guy who might have a heart
might be able to put him out of it she's
like dude I got rid of the light if we
get rid of Susan now that you've
activated it we can transfer its code
directly into the omac No No Miss Clark
it could kill him
Solace billionaire
you're going so fast
here goes nothing
whoa awesome kind of looks like a
butterfly
[Music]
we need to move
beast mode
oh
wow that's awesome
[Music]
yeah awesome
giving me some Justice League vibes
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like I can't miss right
there right there
oh I want him to just go over a bunch of
them and lie down and squish them
activating bug fart
oh oh
gnarly
that's what I do to clear a crowd too
and when it's complete kill the kid so
heartless
oh wow that's a lot oh good you guys
gotta just ruin that I'm really getting
Matrix but how
oh this is where they gotta knock out
the oh yeah he's powering it up okay his
pulse is dropping we'll just fix it
brain break off and get out of there
send me a flashback or is he gonna see
his father
hey
I'm so sad it doesn't always try to be
in
help me with these
oh boy
it's time for you to accept your destiny
guy man
because he's never wanted to have the
suit or be part of it how am I gonna do
this without you
so beautiful
oh it's his dad's necklace
oh these brain waves they're sinking
with the scarce frequency right there
they're connected
yes
[Music]
awesome you're becoming one
oh wow I didn't realize it was already
at a hundred we've got the code the
transfer's complete code is ours
oh damn
yeah he's gonna be way stronger than
before now
[Music]
oh boy loose are gonna destroy the other
ones right oh good he's there so he can
get good that was a great transition
yeah that whole sequence was gorgeous
yeah it was very emotional again to me
that's been the biggest strength of the
film is the the family Dynamic yeah it's
the emotion of the film and the Heart
Second Battle now
my name is you're gonna let him go open
the door
love it in your family and get off this
island okay
what do you mean my family good job we
knew that look in the beginning with
that guy would like somewhere tell her
what your name is it's not sunshine it's
Jose Francisco
[Laughter]
nice
oh no okay all right
oh
wow
no no no no no no no okay good are they
separated though yeah she she pushed her
out of the way I think Jenny's gotta be
on the other side right
Transformer like voice a little bit Yeah
Megatron yeah
I feel like he's about to delete her
just doesn't feel like a person who's
gonna take orders anymore
[Music]
yeah just keep running kid
Cobra Kai karate
we're just the right minute of course
it's a movie oh no his grandma or his
mom someone
yeah so dope
[Music]
thank you
I got this
I love everything that happened right
there
oh my God that's awesome
I love it it's a great movie moment so
fun it's a great movie moment not to be
a Debbie Downer but it's in her son just
Bentley
like I know I'm being a Debbie Downer
she's getting but it was Revenge yeah no
no that's true Sweet Sweet Revenge no no
for sure for sure she's letting it out
right now too for sure
a lot of girls gonna have to save Jen
she's gonna do it with her crazy arm
oh I bet you that sound was her punching
through the rock oh it could be red yeah
with that that thing yeah
I want you both to get it together use
the pain we're feeling and and turn it
into power I want you to go back in
there
[Music]
use it use the first there you called it
yeah I'll get it damn nice job now you
got to use the shield if they shoot at
you hopefully you can switch back fast
enough
okay
starting to break down after too much
hopefully it was just a flesh wound
I love the music change right now it's
awesome
get the hell away from my sister you
ready
that's awesome
yeah nice yeah they're really working in
tandem together
whoa nice
whoa oh
[Music]
damn
nice that's amazing get them all for me
whoa three for the price of one
get over here yeah it's a little
scorpion get over here that was great
yeah get it
that for a
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this
damn he made the Miyagi dough mistake
earlier on he showed Mercy yeah I don't
know if he's gonna do that this time
yeah
wow
nice
wow you do not deserve this power
I mean you're the only reason you're
here is because of his power bro that
line was straight up from Incredible
Hulk
deserve this power give me a sword
ah so I can make whatever weapons I want
huh whatever you can imagine oh cool
nice
huh it's like I got a college degree I
can think of a lot of things
[Music]
whoa
nice
wow cool that was a great move
yes
okay it's a little harder than I thought
yeah oh
[Music]
regenerative systems critical
um
whoa that's the body slam
I don't know
off your future family makes you
win no that's what makes him strong
oh
oh is right
all right when he gets into protective
mode yeah you better watch out
[Music]
whoa
oh yeah I want to see what this book
you're gonna side with that edge keep
track
over your own family I wish the Ted were
here now to see this
oh
what how are you gonna get out oh
they're in the bubble gum okay grew big
I guess yeah whoa okay
he's raging now
get it oh this is superman-esque I love
it
or you think you would threaten my
mother nice
control buddy
cheese what are you doing we're not
Killers
what an interesting card for the
I unlocked his memories yeah he's also a
family and he was probably forced into
this too
oh he's had a tough life
oh God that's sad
but we saw that locket he had uh I feel
like he had a wife and
okay
oh is his mom and him no
[Music]
oh boy
what's so sad you're wrong
I love
that I have for my family it's my
strength that's what makes me fun
Familia
huh
they come in here
he's maxing out the energy reactor in
his suit I advise me back away oh no
stop now
sacrifice this must be
together
yeah wow oh my God you better fly buddy
whoa
and she's strong to be holding that too
must be on a good workout plan
ah whoa well the it's it's titanium
armor probably some kind
Grandma I didn't know you were such a
badass
okay so that nitpick I had earlier was
this is justifying it much more now I'm
looking forward as I was saying will
will no longer make weapons it's not
about taking from the community we're
giving back to the community
you can start by building them a new
house okay
and look at this we always do I love
that he's wearing his dad's necklace
it's sweet
I know he's gonna be dating Jenny but
she's gotta help out somehow she was
responsible in certain manner I'm sure
she will
where am I we don't have a house I think
it's time to return the edge case of the
people that made it great it sounds like
the Reyes family is rubbing off a little
bit on Jenny cardinal
cord Industries will fix and give you
back your house
thank you
that's here Rudy what's this new car
I got you a new tailgate
wow it's blue on the nose no Rudy I
gotta go
yeah
[Music]
how about I walk you up not such a good
smile that was smooth where are you
headed
to my dad's what if I gave you a ride
oh I feel a surge of blood rushing
towards your mid feet
what's it say
this is a more appropriate time to kiss
I like cats backlit and the wind's
blowing I would always make sure I wore
the worst clothes possible
hang on hold on
I'm so scared me too I'd be like holy
yeah no I'm taking the motorcycle oh my
God I'm not doing that
okay hey we got a Gordon here heck yes
that was so fun
I loved it I like I also love it at the
heart of this movie is all about love
and family Familia yeah and they really
like a lot of movies try to like kind of
uh put that in there like love and
family but they don't actually show it
this movie showed it by bringing in all
of the family members to actually play a
huge part and it's not just Blue Beetle
in in taking down the enemy right yeah
um as I mentioned at the beginning I
don't know a ton about the character of
Blue Beetle but that was my favorite
part of the film excuse me it was uh the
family aspect that excuse me we'll come
back to that are we gonna see what
happened to Ted the father
let's see
the original Blue Beetle has he been
hiding in plain sight the whole time
[Music]
is he inside that thing and that's why
the pillows are covering the ding dong
with the belt
or
my computer
very subtle tell my daughter I'm alive
Ted Court
he's like I have to say the first name
and last name
um first of all it's giving me credit I
called it you called it I'm sure that
most people call them you call a lot of
things no no no no no I'm just saying
I'm sure most people were able to
predict and the mid credits or post
credits that uh the uh was gonna involve
Ted Decor that was uh they're pretty
sure that was obvious oh yeah yeah but
still uh like I said earlier I I don't
know much about the character of Blue
Beetle other than the little bit I've
seen on Smallville and uh in Injustice 2
and I did like what I saw for the little
bit there but
um I I just love again I'm always a
sucker for a good family story and I
just I love the infusion and the dynamic
between the family uh the father was I
mean again I love the whole family they
were also great the grandpa was such a
badass yeah um but I love uh especially
the dad he was such a rock I mean having
the house being taken away from them I
mean the triple the tax or whatever uh
and then the heart attack that's just
having to kill after that
um but still being such a light of
positivity like through all the
hardships that they're going to because
that's what they needed and like that's
just a good lesson for them even after
he's gonna be gone and I know that was
kind of movie trophy okay we're having
our family moments and we know we gotta
lose them and obviously very movie
trophy but still even though we knew
that was gonna happen it's that it's the
way they executed it that you know and I
was just so invested in him and the rest
of the family that even after it
happened I was like okay it's the
lessons he taught them so that you know
when him and uh forgot the name of the
scare of the Kaji or whatever the name
oh yeah the Scarab yeah yeah whatever it
is um that when the infusion did happen
and when he sees his dad in the
afterlife I'll uh Black Panther or
whatever uh it's just like it was really
earned to me
um so that like you know when I I just I
really bought that moment and like just
the lessons again that he he learned
from his father and like no I it's not
only that I've got to infuse with this
thing and accept my destiny but also
that I've got to become the man of the
family and and be like the father as
well uh kind of thing um yeah the family
so I just I like the two lessons that he
had to learn in that about you know
Destiny and that kind of thing and the
positive light that we that I've got to
be not only for my family but on the
world yeah and I like that they brought
in their own culture like in the
flashback with the dad
um the the way that he's all lit by the
candles and they already had like a
remembrance Corner in their house even
when they were all there together so
bringing their part of culture and the
way they that the flashback happened and
that the dad was basically saying I know
now what my fate was is to have those
heart attacks and to die so that I could
be here with you and send you back for
your own destiny absolutely which was
it's an amazing message and it's really
it was that whole scene was really
beautiful the colors it was it was the
world disappearing from from behind them
right it was like they were on an island
and the world kind of going away to
force him into space to to basically
meet his like Blue Beetle uh personality
that'll have for the rest of his life
kind of a thing I really love that whole
thing about like you know his uh Jaime
you know the humanity in him you know
wouldn't allow himself to delete anyone
or specifically that the right that main
villain that he was fighting throughout
the film and then you know again I'm
sorry that I keep forgetting the name of
the scare but whatever Kaji or whatever
it was
um you know was trying to Hill
throughout the whole excuse me delete
throughout the whole picture and then
like towards the end it reverted like I
did not see that coming and I always
love when I can be shocked and twisted
or whatever you want to call it in films
but in a satisfactory way and I really
love that it was kind of like a
character Arc for the Scarab itself yeah
but in again just done in such a
satisfying way and I look I just did not
see that coming in any way because again
you could feel his anger and you know
even though he didn't particularly
delete his father you know he was part
of the team that you know was involved
in doing it so you could understand
Jaime's rage and anger and any one of us
in that situation would have wanted to
do the same thing even though he wasn't
a violent person and always you know
looked at deleting human beings as a
very last resort so like again his rage
and anger were totally understandable
and even like I'm sure either of us
would unders like almost
doing that of course in that situation I
do feel though with that villain um
again I do like at the end what they
were showing with his family I did feel
a sense of sympathy but to me it was I
mean I know the film wasn't about him
was about Jaime and his family and his
journey
um it was all from his perspective but I
feel like it was a little too too little
too late in terms of just showing all
that stuff I would have liked a little
more about the feeling it didn't even
need to be even if it was more in the
middle of the picture I just feel it was
a OneNote generic type of film and even
Susan Sarandon's character it's just
very one note I did not care about it
right at all
um she was obviously fantastic actress
I've enjoyed many films version
performances but I just did not care
about the character in any way shape or
form yeah I'm evil and yeah I'm like
okay it's kind of like when you when you
see the foundation that they set with
him
um when they go back to his family and
he's remembering it it's like any Disney
or Pixar film hold on we're getting to
soon yes those creds the cartoon we
wanted they're the animated film
are they still watching in the security
booth
[Music]
I would love it if Jaime and Jenny
you're watching this on date night yeah
oh that was great
um oh don't touch that now we should
react to that I was gonna say how it's
like every Disney and Pixar movie right
you show the foundation of the family
before and the sad stuff that happens so
that as we're following the character
you feel a little bit more for them yeah
um it's the same thing they didn't
really show too much about
um Susan like with her brother and why
it was so bad we were just told it so
there was a lot of exposition there of
of us being told what the relationship
was like but I think specifically with
him and the suit it's that he taught the
suit we were waiting for that moment
when it's like that they're supposed to
link up the suit is teaching him so much
but in the beginning we we realized the
suit is so intelligent it does learn
from Jaime and that in the very
beginning he's like we are not killers
and the suit was ready to become a
killer but it learns from its owner so
in the end when it protects him and
protects like basically the moral code
that Jaime set up for the suit in the
very beginning without him knowing he's
setting up a more code is the suit
saying we're not killers and reminding
him that we don't do that you know it
stopped him there from uh which we all
know your emotions can get you in the
worst possible places and he was in a
place that it was going to get him
nowhere and he would have not felt great
after that fact so it was cool that the
suit came for him and set kind of this
moral code that we now see yeah he is he
is not a killer
um and I thought
a little bit with with the uh the
villain dragging suits random like into
the fire I knew that he was probably
gonna go hey
let's just go join my mom because like
what am I gonna do here now if I have to
like serve her but I did I I did like
there had to be at some point where
Somebody's gotta get rid of her
otherwise she's just gonna keep coming
back right as the villain and it was a
nice move to set up the girl to be like
a CEO I just
um I guess it's it's kind of cool to see
it like she made him and now he's like
well you know I'm getting ready you know
um wasn't like a huge surprise to me but
I I still liked it yeah yeah I mean
that's that would probably be I mean
there's a there's a lot there was a lot
of predictable stuff for sure in here um
but I I really do agree with you uh
from her perspective and her hate hair
hatred for her family and her brother uh
I mean that was a lot of exposition more
telling rather than showing I wouldn't
um even I again I know it's anime's
story and his family but I would not
even mind it like even a flashback yeah
I know they told us yeah yeah and I I
know they showed us like hey they gave
everything to her or to him to Ted and
kind of like threw her and I I could
understand that resentment like I get
that I if that were me I wouldn't be
happy about that either but if you show
some kind of a flashback scene maybe
Ted's being some kind of a dick I'm like
oh my God like okay she's still the
villain but Ted's being a dick about
this like I'm kind of like I'm not
rooting for her but I really understand
her motivation and like I I get it now
like why she's doing what she's doing
like even from this one flashback scene
right now kind of thing so I think you
make a really good point like that would
have added a lot more Dimension to her
character in terms of like you're just
you're
no just because she doesn't want to go
along with your evil right yeah and that
came around quick I think the only real
um Insight we got to her is when they
cut to
um one of them looking at a picture of
her which Susan Sarandon had dark hair
she looked a lot younger and they made
the comment saying she was different
back then meaning
um I feel like she in the video we kept
saying like human humanitarian like she
was a humanitarian but I think then she
was already set in this way of like I'm
the CEO and I'm getting my brother
really screwed me over versus before I
think it might not have actually been
her brother it might have just been the
choice of like who the power was given
to yes and that power being given away
uh really is what set her off and it
might not have been her brother at all
and maybe they didn't maybe they didn't
want to reveal it but they still could
have given us maybe a little flashback
of just maybe when they were kids or how
much the the whole businessman meant to
her and why the power being take taken
away from her would have pushed her to
where she is today and again you even
could have had a scene too where like
you see that the father is uh the hurt
Susan Sarandon's father is talking to
Ted saying you know I could never give
it to Susan whatever I forgot her name
uh her character like she's too unstable
like that sets her off the deep just
something like that whatever there's so
many different things you could have
done
um like that
um and yeah I know and again I kind of
said this during the reaction I just
love seeing the the dichotomy and
differences of the family Dynamics
between the two different families uh
it's interesting to see uh you know you
got the the loving family of Jaime and
then with Jenny she's in such a screwed
up I mean obviously I would assume Ted
was so loving to her towards her I mean
you could see you could see how much
love Jenny had towards uh him but
obviously with uh Susan Sarandon being
her aunt I mean that's completely a torn
family there so I I just love seeing the
difference and like and how again it was
such a strength behind me and you know
uh obviously you know for uh for Jen he
was just something she had to work
against
um but yeah yeah but again I I just I
love that was my favorite part of this
movie it's like it's not the the cool
visuals or the cool fights and high-tech
stuff you know when they're in the Blue
Beetle suit and all that like that I
mean it's cool to look at it's
entertaining but the family Dynamic and
the emotional stuff that's that was my
favorite part of the film by far I mean
you guys always know I always say it if
the movie doesn't have heart I kind of
check out this movie had a lot of heart
which I fully appreciated and I think
what really represents the family is
towards the end when they welcome her in
I mean she was initially an enemy right
she brought kind of these problems in in
you know on the on the outskirts to
their family and they lost a lot during
that process but
um the way that they are built and their
own moral code which fed into him and
then feeds into the suit and feeds into
that this is is all just like a blessing
for the entire family and it is his
Destiny and now we'll be able to like
protect them it's nice to see them like
take her in and then her be able to give
back to them in a really huge way
absolutely great Point again that that
moment at the end with the suit where
she infused her like learning the moral
code and putting it I mean that really
was one of them I I was so shocked and
surprised by that in all the right ways
I I just really wasn't expecting that
and I am so happy that they put that in
the film like that what a smart choice
like yeah just real like I just wasn't
expecting the scare of it sorry again
the name I just wasn't expecting the
Scarab to get that character Arc itself
right I loved all the conversations they
were having I know it kind of felt a
little Jarvis Iron Man but what I mean
it is what it is the same kind of thing
but yeah yeah exactly but I I just I
love the way again their their
relationship kind of just like
progressed throughout the film too and
as I got comfortable with each each
other as he like you know made it his
Destiny to be the Blue Beetle but again
that was one of my if not my favorite
moments uh in the film was that moment
oh yeah I loved it so much and the
grandma just the grandma man that's
awesome 10 out of 10. I know I made that
little nitpick like why why isn't she
emoting a little more sad because her
son just but you know on the flip side
again she's kind of letting it out right
there and like having a a fun little
moment and then afterwards when it was
all when the adrenaline had died down it
was kind of back to being said so I'm
glad they put that back in there I was
like okay now it's a little more
grounded that makes more sense so yeah
I'm sure a lot of you were like shut up
lover ever moment I I admit that was I
know I'm seriously I'm glad that they
put that moment in there where it's like
okay it's adrenaline has died down it's
time to you know be sad now about uh
what what has just occurred so right
yeah yeah they had to kick it into gear
um I would give it I'm gonna give it an
eight out of ten I was gonna go maybe
eight maybe even 8.5
I I really liked it I thought I thought
it was a blast and specifically because
it had a heart it made it extra fun I
think I'll stick to eight eight out of
ten it is a fun time what about you I
probably go like a seven out of ten
seven out of ten yeah very good still a
good score yeah still a good score a
good movie we had fun I mean any last
stops before we get out of here no just
uh I'm if they do make us it was a good
first entry into the James Gunn Universe
I know a lot of people are not uh
exactly enthusiastic about that just
because the whole Henry Cavill thing
which I'm not I wasn't the biggest fan
of of course I'm looking forward to his
version of it which comes out of my
birthday in a few years to say
um but uh I again for I I really love to
show up by the way we didn't even talk
about Jolo as uh uh Jaime he did such a
terrific job and he's great it's gonna
Gail and Cobra Kay everyone in here was
very believable really grounded great
acting in the beginning I was a little
worried about uh Jen it just initially I
was was like oh who is this girl do I
totally believe her she dropped in and
then she did and she was really good at
um being emotional which is great
um which I really thoroughly enjoyed but
I I really liked everybody yeah and
again really quick not knowing too much
about this character if they do make
sequels to this film maybe in the second
film or even a third film to even get
that far I would love to see them play
around like again the psychology and
emotionality in terms of like what does
this do to hide me like maybe play
around with the dark side kind of like
I'll uh you know when Spider-Man gets
the black suit and kind of goes like all
uh emo type of thing I'd love to see
them play around with that version of
the character
um but overall I thought this was again
the the family Dynamic I thought that
was the heart of the film I was my
favorite part and I love that moment at
the end where the Scarab just uh you
know reclaimed and kept his Humanity I
thought that was just such a well
executed and such an earned character
Arc for the Scarab it was yeah just
didn't see that coming I was so
thoroughly really appreciative and
surprised by that and uh yeah really
good that's it we love it leave a like
leave a comment you know ring the bell
tell us we're great we love you so much
be cool be nice be kind enjoy kind of
spooky season almost yeah that's it
we'll see you soon bye
foreign